dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly FA hair dear fellow
scholars this is two minute papers with
károly Jean is ahead close enough as you
have probably noticed today we are going
to talk about text to speech or TTS in
short TTS means that we write a piece of
text and the computer synthesized voice
will read it aloud for us this is really
useful for reading the news or creating
audio books that don't have any official
voiceovers this work was done by
researchers at Princeton University and
Adobe and is about text-based audio
narration editing this one is going to
be crazy good the Adobe guys like to
call this the Photoshop of voiceovers in
a normal situation we have access to a
waveform and if you wish to change
anything in a voiceover we need to edit
it
editing waveforms by hand is extremely
difficult traditional techniques often
can't even reliably find the boundaries
between words and letters let alone edit
them and with this technique we can cut
copy and even edit this text and the
waveforms will automatically be
transformed appropriately using the same
voice had it struck squarely it would
have killed him
had it struck squarely it would have
saved him we can even use new words that
have never been uttered in the original
narration we leave the eventualities to
time and law
we leave the eventualities to time em
believe
believe belief belief the
the
we leave the eventualities to time and
belief we leave the eventualities to
time and belief
sauce an optimization problem where the
similarity smoothness and the pace of
the original footage is to be matched as
closely as possible one of the excellent
new features is that we can even choose
from several different voicings for the
new word and insert the one that we deem
the most appropriate for expert users
the page and duration is also editable
it is always important to have a look at
a new technique and make sure that it
works well in practice but in science
this is only the first step there has to
be more proof that a new proposed method
works well in a variety of cases in this
case a theoretical proof by means of
mathematics is not feasible
therefore a user study was carried out
where listeners were shown synthesized
and real audio samples and had to
blindly decide which was which the
algorithm was remarkably successful at
deceiving the test subjects make sure to
have a look at the paper in the
description for more details
this technique is traditional in a sense
that it doesn't use any sort of neural
networks however there are great strides
being made in that area as well which I
am quite excited to show you in future
episodes and due to some of these newer
video and audio editing techniques I
expect that within the internet forums
safe news is going to be an enduring
topic I hope that in parallel with
better and better text and video
synthesis there will be an arms race
with other methods that are designed to
identify these cases a neural detective
if you will and now if you excuse me
I'll give this publicly available TPS
one more try and see if I can retire
from narrating videos thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time
yep exact same thing that you didn't
even notice it
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you
you